I only dated one man this past year and
it would it did not go very well for me
but it I just feel like with what you
were saying I really don't find many
options for me right now like where I
live and it does get smaller and smaller
and I I feel like the standards
definitely trims down your options
What's um what happened with the guy
that you dated that didn't go so well um
actually believe it or not I met him on
a dating website called hinge I don't
know if you anyone familiar with that it
was very Okay so
not even from here um we dated for like
a couple months you know talking here
and there and we were going out a couple
times and once I started nursing back up
I was like because this is during the
summer this is when I was dating him
during the summer when I wasn't in
school and I had that time off and I was
just working full-time in the ER um I
said you know like when I start school
again like I want to cut things off but
in this time frame of we were hanging
out like I really actually like this man
and that has not happened for me and I
could not tell you how like how long it
was
forever and um how old was he Zoe and
what did he do for a living so he
previously worked for the US Senate and
he did like Congress work and he was in
law school like around this
area and um and his age he was 24 okay
so very successful for 24 I agree and I
feel like he had a really good head on
his shoulders you know he kind of had
like the things I was looking for in a
man he's was extremely sweet and I think
we just got along so well like we
clicked initially and I've never even
gone on a hinge date before or you know
let alone gone out with man recently so
I was like wow like this is you know
this is that was pretty good like I'm
gonna reach out to him again and see
like if we could you know talk again and
see where like where both our headset
are at and he's like I have family
coming in town I would love for you to
come down and meet them I'm like that's
wonderful
in that week we actually ran into each
other at a bar and this was like a
couple months after like we ended kind
of things and he pretended like Zoe you
were telling us an interesting story
before you cut out there it was kind of
peeking okay so like what was like the
last thing that you heard you saw him at
the bar ran into him at the bar okay so
that same week that he like was texting
me all week like wanting to meet up we
ran into him at the bar like this is
around Halloween time and he was with
like his friends from like law school
and um he acted like he had no idea who
I was and I think he got caught with
another girl you know like he was with
another girl and I think he was dating
another girl so that was that was the
end of that story and five days later I
got blocked on everything that same
weekend he wanted me to meet some of his
family coming in town so that was like
that I was like I had no idea like what
happened like I did not do anything
wrong I said hello to him gave him a hug
it was a very short Interruption and I
got like the most oh my gosh look that
I've ever had in my entire life I was
like oh my gosh that was so bad I get
home that same night and he tries to
Snapchat me and I'm like why would I
want to talk to somebody that completely
ignored me at a bar like didn't even
want to catch up we haven't talked for a
months since like the previous time we
were going out during the summer and I
was I left it on Open five days later I
get blocked on everything so so that was
the end of that story and I have not
dated anyone since so was there a gal
there with him that night um yes I mean
but I didn't think anything of it
truthfully like I was just like you know
like why would he be reaching out to me
making plans to me that same weekend you
know but yeah do think that that way
what do you think of a guy that's at
that level that's in law school deals
with Congress politician sort of stuff
I'm assuming he was a good-looking guy
very and that like that another hard
thing that I can't really find anyone
that I'm attracted to and he was like
one of the first guys that I was
generally attracted to okay so so he's
taking off a lot of boxes for you so I'm
sure you understand there's going to be
more than just Zoe competing for his
attention right because he's a high
value guy so
what's what's the issue with pursuing a
guy like that if if you know you dig his
vibe to that level you know like he's
he's the only guy that you found that
attractive in the span of time that
you've been dating right so what if you
see another G like they're not exclusive
right like he's talking about inviting
you to see his family exactly um I knew
in the back of my head I was like
there's no way that you know I met him
and I you know was like wow like this
guy is great that other women wasn't
think like were not thinking the same
exact thing so he messaged you that
night on Snapchat and you didn't read it
you didn't acknowledge it
nothing yeah like we were texting that
day right that that we you know ran into
so why would he message you on Snapchat
instead of texting you then
exactly weird yeah didn't what do the
they don't do text anymore they just
only Snapchat these young people yeah
you're gonna have to forgive Me Maybe
for being a little bit think and
disconnected from Snapchat the appeal is
Rich the appeal is that the messages
disappear so it's like a it's like
setting signal messages disappear after
5 minutes or something like that pretty
much or they open they they disappear as
soon as they're opened unless you
screenshot or something like that got it
got it if they screenshot it so they
could be like why are you and keep in
mind like we never really snapchot it
before like this was like okay out of
the blue like just Snapchatting me like
letting me know that he got home I don't
I couldn't tell you okay well it sounds
like he did something a little bit Goofy
on on his end but I still kind of want
to press you on this question a little
bit more so high value guy you find him
attractive you don't find that other
guys you're dealing with he's dealing
with other women obviously so now you
know this you know he's in he's in
demand he sends you a message you dig
his Vibe but you ignore it and then you
get blocked several days later are you
surprised igned it um I was kind of
shocked because I I ignored it okay but
I kind of was thinking Some of head like
what did I do wrong like what made me
get blocked because I've never been
blocked by a man before like this is all
the only thing that you did wrong was
that you didn't respond to
him right because like what was up about
this you know tonight but like that's
not my place to be like and I didn't no
no but you know what the message was
like were you ble to read it in advance
or you can only read it if you open it
it was a picture of him sitting in bed
at 2:30 in the morning did it have a
caption or something or just blink just
a picture of him laying in bed yep
that's it so 24 year old gu immature and
Goofy yeah it's an invitation more than
anything but it's like
see for for the gals watching and for
you Zoe like the amount of guys that are
going to tick off all these boxes for
you gals that that you have a strong
attraction of four that you have a a
Lust For even they're they're rare and a
lot of women compete for them and the
thing is is that high value successful
guys like that are not common on the
sexual Marketplace beautiful women are
everywhere right I mean if you go to
Instagram and you do a search on hashtag
fitnessgirl millions of results will pop
up objectively with nines and tens some
of them 11s you know in some cases
really hot women so there's so there's
loads and loads of really hot women out
there but the kind of guy that you're
looking for that that that really draws
you in and captivates your heart is
pretty rare so I would encourage you in
the future you know if you find a guy
like that not to take it easy on them
and to you know just not follow through
on something because like women will be
competing for his attention like there's
no question about that I really didn't
think twice about it honestly and remind
me why you guys stopped seeing each
other like why you wanted to end things
you're like going back to school or
something like that I was just going
back to school and I just I really don't
like talking to people people like when
I'm in school but then like when I was
alone for a couple weeks I was like wait
I generally enjoyed his company like
this was different than I'm you know I'm
used to and I was like wait did I just
screw up like did I mess up like not
continuing to pursue him like a little
bit a little bit yeah yeah that was that
was yeah but the blocking is so immature
that he just lost a lot of points with
that yeah but if he's got lots of
options he's got so many op are you
kidding me he lives in Naples if he's
got lots of options and a girl blocks
them he's just going to be like ah
whatever I'll just go to the next one he
does to block her that's I've never been
blocked before so like that was
new have you ever dated a guy of that
caliber no there you go um I mean I
previously talked to someone that you
know worked for American Airlines but I
just I wasn't really attracted to him as
much yeah he was a pilot but I just
didn't have that attraction but this man
had the same exact you know really good
career but but he was attractive so like
that was
like yeah yeah well there you go I mean
like you're going to have to um you know
the thing is is that women have been
told this story over and over again no
you're worth girl don't put up with this
that and the other thing I see this on
social media all the time like women
telling other women um you know if he
takes you on these places for dates and
you have to disqualify him if he does
this disqualify him if he has an Android
disqualify him it's like they routinely
try to find ways for for women to
convince other women to be miserable and
single by disqualifying men for reasons
that are just simple like oh he sent me
or you know he didn't acknowledge me
enough at the bar when he was out there
with his friends and probably another
gal which is reasonable right because
he's out there with them and her
probably but a little bit of a a Chase
from you Zoe might have got his
attention on it right and originally
that's how we started like I wasn't
paying attention to him he you know know
oh sorry I can't like hang out this
weekend you know he'd have to wait a
couple weeks or you know just stuff like
that and I didn't think twice about it
because I was still like doing my own
thing during the summer hanging out with
my friends so it wasn't like a constant
like I'm available to him and I think
initially that's what attracted him to
me and I was constantly working and um
during school that obviously changed and
I was like I would do anything to hang
out with this man now I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out